l'aco vide elle est elle aussi infectée
l'internet
l'inquiétude à travers le monde était
telle que très vite
netflix youtube et compagnie ont accepté
de réduire leur débit c'est à dire la
qualité de leurs images sur la bande
passante comme on l'appelle et la bande
passante à cause de la pandémie a été
utilisé comme jamais et l'a tenu le coup
internet est devenue la source de la
direction mais là on est l'ex youtube et
autres et donc ça ça a été quand même
assez situation qui est un ajout de
trafic qui n'étaient pas présents avant
d'apprendre mis en valeur par le
confinement car les images les vidéos
c'est ce qui pèse le plus sur la bande
passante la bande passante c'est la
quantité d'informations en mode binaire
pouvant être retransmise simultanément
par un réseau internet
elle se mesure en bits par seconde on
peut mesurer la vitesse de transmission
des données dans les deux sens
descendant et ascendants plus le débit
est élevé plus votre service internet et
rapide et efficace cela se passe par le
réseau de téléphone de câbles de fibre
optique et de cellulaires de votre
fournisseur
le tout simultanément avec l'aco vide
pas de surprise les gens regarder
davantage de films et de séries mais le
confinement à apporter des nouveautés de
trafic internet a aussi quitté confinées
à la maison donc celui qui a écopé le
plus de cette surcharge de tafer c'était
en fait le fournisseur d'accès internet
le crâne qu'icbc relais en fait les
règles les résidences les types de
demandes aussi a changé parce que on a
beaucoup de on a beaucoup de demandes
des trafics qui a des petits pas vidéo
conférence et lé travail et ainsi de
suite
et tout ça en même temps c'est s'était
fait qu est la demande globalement
augmenté aussi des phénomènes qui sont
pas réjouissants pour quelqu'un qui voit
planifié
résultat les grands fournisseurs comme
bell rogers telus shaw et vidéotron ont
constaté des hausses de
à 50 % des téléchargements mais surtout
de 30 à 70% plus de téléversement c'est
à dire du domicile vers internet les
réseaux de partage vidéo ont vu leur
utilisation explosé skype plus 200% team
de microsoft 500% et zoom 2 574% le
télétravail à grande échelle ce n'était
pas prévu une grande surprise parce que
ces applications n'ont jamais su
vraiment au le menu professionnel a
évidemment ils vont tous par la suite
développé une application allemand alors
la qualité n'est pas au rendez vous on
le constate tous les jours à la
télévision
coupure mauvaise image décalage on a
besoin de nouvelles technologies
mais c'est exactement ce que la saignée
je réglais de régler pour quand même
d'un attaquant donc il va y avoir des
améliorations de latence on s'entend on
parle même de faire des djs tente donc
faut vraiment bien la latence sont
négligeables pour des opérateurs
fournisseurs de contenus médiatiques
pour les entreprises dans de menus la
scène j ai beaucoup de promesses
oui les réseaux a résisté mais
vraisemblablement c'est parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup soutenu
est-ce que ça m'étonne bon évidemment a
posteriori trop facile de dire je le
savais parce qu'on est quand même assez
joyeux canada en haut on ne peut être
pas se l'admettre mais ce secteur qui
est ouvert à la compétition vous
justement dans cette situation de prise
on aime la diversité on aime beaucoup de
gens se sont investis dans les réseaux
et dans les sciers et ça peut nous
offrir un paquet d'options en fait c'est
tout l'internet
après la copie dit li a désormais un
nouveau normal et oui les réseaux a
résisté mais vraisemblablement c'est
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
capacités un peu plus maintenant
heskey dans les nouveaux normal est-ce
qu'il ya encore beaucoup des capacités a
soutenu le monde de l'internet ne sera
plus jamais le même
[Musique]
avec les mêmes réseaux il ya des uns ou
n'auraient pas pu fonctionner comme on
est en train d'être sanctionné
actuellement tout le monde devrait avoir
accès à l'internet à haute vitesse
c'est pas un par les cas partout au
canada en dehors des centres urbains les
citoyens canadiens sont encore très
désavantagé
[Musique]